bon je vous explique la présentation d
honneur 20 au nord un pro a élu
aujourd'hui là on est le soir il quelque
chose comme temps délaissé va regarder
il est 21h 49 heure de londres produit
très sympa les produits sont vraiment
très très prometteur j'ai pu les prendre
en main très rapidement des produits je
trouve vraiment intéressante mais ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'on est vraiment dans
la période de crise pour plusieurs
raisons vous savez je le déjà prêt dans
une précédente vidéo il ya un problème
entre les états unis et la chine
huawei fait les frais de sa d'une guerre
commerciale sans rentrer dans le détail
tout de suite en tout cas on l'a
vraiment vu on l'a vraiment perçu dans
l'événement à aucun moment le mot google
est prononcé ce qu'on fait c'est que je
vous emmène avec moi vous allez voir on
est quand même sur une présentation qui
n'est pas dans la même dynamique que
d'habitude
et pour cause
[Musique]
nous voilà arrivés à londres qu'on va
aller parler justement le mono review
vent non au nom voilà à londres pour
venir parler aujourd'hui du haut normand
voilà bien le cros et 20 pro ali prenant
en photo là pour l'instant
vas-y fais la poste naturel fait la base
naturelle et la botte naturel
d'instagram ça c'est naturel sa maison
ils vont penser que tarek relou en fait
[Musique]
ça mais d'apple vous allez arrêter avec
vos photos la lega la regarde lui une
pose naturelle des bouches pas les
spielberg qui bossent pousse pas
[Musique]
vous aussi c'est qu'ils vont ils vont
pas arrêter de me voir à chaque fois sur
cette vidéo ils vont encore marc messier
mais je ne vais pas fan du bouton côté
on est derrière nice et youtube heures à
ce que pareil à une soirée aujourd'hui
je reste à londres ont pas ouais on va
seulement club electro région de rigoler
si par tout tout tout tout tout tout
danger un montage à faire ouais voilà je
vais après tu te réveilles pas pour
prendre des trois méthodes noir le plus
de badges maintenant pourquoi et nous
filent plus de badges maintenant une
fausse j'aime bien les collections nous
voilà arrivés sur place donc là on
l'événement va commencer dans quelques
instants nous emmène je vous montre
rapidement la sa uras regardant ses
jolies formes là du cloud a eu le crâne
on a le cloud offre est juste là si vous
voulez parce que c'est elle qui fait
qu'il est inquiet il est là haut normand
série de captures revendeur donc vous en
douterez aujourd'hui on va parler du
honor badge et au dos reis est venu pour
ça que la zone de démonstration pour
l'instant à ligne il n'y a pas de
produits ya pas de smartphone
on a ça là qu'est ce qu'on voit là bas
on voit au nord et moschino prix donc là
c'est pareil on est un petit jeu
d'israël toujours avec moschino ici et
on a au fond là on voit un truc au nord
20 + 39 tous en 20 rencontres juste
après et au fond il ya la salle de
congrès commence à se remplir tout
doucement énorme
c'est très très grand ou je pense que là
c'est pareil ça va envoyer du bois
j'espère juste la voix quelques instants
et donc beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
monde
présentation officielle s'intéressent
encore plus aujourd'hui il ya un enjeu
et parce que vous le savez il ya eu
l'annoncent comme quoi aujourd'hui au
nord ne travaillait plus est au fait de
travailler plus avec google donc là sur
ce modèle là je pense que ça va rester
comme ça on va donc avoir un android
avec mieux sans aucun problème mais sur
les versions suivantes il sera beaucoup
plus compliqué pour lui
on en reparle dans quelques instants
webagoo jusque là qu'on les aura les
gars je suis pas du tout permis
c'est con mais enfin tu te fout de la
gueule a présenté deux nouveaux
smartphones le honorant et le
haut-normand gros smartphone son papier
à tout l'air assez intéressant nos gros
focus qui est fait c'est au niveau de la
photo au niveau de l'écran et au niveau
des performances
les trois points importants alors ça on
les testeront leur viendra plus tard
lors des phases de test bien évidemment
non je vis tout de suite à vous abonner
comme ça que vous saurez tout un modèle
un peu plus boosté c'est le modèle pro
surtout au niveau de la photo parce que
au niveau des performances est
exactement la même chose au niveau de
l'écran c'est exactement la même chose
alors je vous explique un petit peu ce
qui se passe j'ai vu une petite fiche
ici j'ai tout noté nous annonce un
nouveau design quatre capteurs photo
c'est ça il ya quatre capteurs photo
derrière quatre capteurs photo à
l'arrière sans le modèle pro à 48
mégapixels c'est la sony mx 5 186
content d'être là de faire pas mal de
photos intéressantes notamment photo
nuit avec une ouverture à f 1.4
stabilisation électronique stabilisation
optique sur quatre axes
on a une caméra 16 mégapixels qui ouvre
à f 2.2 c'est un très grand angle 217
degré on a également un tel objectif de
8 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4 avec une
stabilisation optique dessus on assume
optique x 3,1 zoom numérique x 10 et un
zoom hybrid4
affaire à suivre et on a également un
objectif de 2 mégapixels pour le mode
macro qui ouvre à f 2.4 fallu faire des
macro 4 cm de distance on a un autofocus
laser
la netteté pour le point sagot vous en
douterez nous annonce également une
vidéo stabiliser sans le testera donc ça
peut être aussi intéressant du point de
vue de la vidéo voir ce que honor va
nous proposer sur son honneur 20 et en
euros du côté du honor va on n'avait
qu'à bernard de 48 mégapixels c'est
toujours la saône et yannick 586 tour
cette fois-ci à f 1.8
on a un très grand angle de 16
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 et on a une
caméra de 2 mégapixels pour le mode
portrait pour les faits évoqués ils ont
absolument pas donné d'informations sur
l'ouverture et la toujours à cette
caméra de 2 mégapixels pour le mode
macro qui ose toujours à 2.4 on nous
annonce un grand capteur photo plus
grand que ce qui se ferait à la
concurrence ça également affaire à
suivre
un super night shot un mode qui vous
permet de combiner 16 explosion
différents pour sortir la meilleure
photo en photo nuit et honda à l'avant
une caméra de 30 2 mégapixels qui ouvre
à f 2.0
bonjour monsieur vous venez pour faire
un reportage moi je fais des plans et je
fais des plans at elle soufflé sortie de
la planète en émoi
voilà on a un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui s'est tu sur la tranche
pour le déverrouiller a priori en 0,3
seconde ça également refait rassure
c'est un capteur reste est plus standard
donc normalement ça marche parfaitement
bien on a un écran percée avec les
petites caméras de 32 médiatique c'est
bon ça c'est un design convoi arrivé
depuis le début d'année à tout folichon
folichon mais ça peut être plutôt pas
mal on a un dos avec un design
holographique vous avez trois couches de
cet effet un petit peu reflet relief ça
c'est vraiment très très très sympa un
dos en verre vous avez un écran de 6,2
26 pouces qui a priori très dans un form
factor dans 5,3 pouces âge demande à
voir sa part effectivement en prise en
main relativement intéressant à voir à
l'usagé sera d'envoyer c'est vrai que ce
sont enfin fan factor pour voir qu'on a
un écran très grand chose ça plutôt pas
mal qu'est ce qu'elle en pense failli
bouton
passe magnifique c'est pas mal non mais
c'est vrai il faut un peu de temps pour
voir qu'on a décrit si bien
c'est très sympa
url et 5 fautes en l'air de déranger
annonce un score sur indique son manque
de sens en ce sens
trois mois c'est vrai cette couleur là
avec ses effets alors ça c'est drôle
blacks ça c'est la couleur mars et le
fantôme bluey les verts trucs bizarres
chine au nord cette année mais bon
maintenant
ouais j'ai compris en scène etc c'est
très sympa et voyez ce petit effet avec
en a racheté les revoir merci avec la
petite caméra n'a 30 2 mégapixels c'est
pas mal alors on a un enfant qui a un
petit peu plus grand mais c'est pas non
plus complètement déconneur donc c'est
vrai smartphone qu'en tout cas sur le
papier a l'air bien la prise en manège
ne trouve pas trop lourd relativement
sympa côté performances sur les deux
modèles on a bien évidemment un kirin
980 on a de l'intelligence artificielle
un truc surboosté avec le gpu turbo 3.0
donc ça marche c'est bien c'est pratique
on a deux versions sans modèle normal
vous avez une version 6 giga de ram avec
128 go de stockage
donner le prix dans quelques instants et
son modèle 3 vous avez glee giga de ram
256 go de stockage
on nous annonce également un partenariat
avec forte que nous avons été très très
rapidement un petit gagnent pas de qu'on
pourrait mettre en joue avec moi c'est
pareil là dessus on a absolument aucune
information complémentaire au niveau de
la batterie
on a sur le modèle normal une batterie
de 3750 milliers en paire eur / modèles
trop 4000 milliampères heures avec de la
recharge rapide 22.5 watts de la
recharge bien évidemment en usb type c
et on a bien évidemment la question de
l' os magic yoann nous ont absolument
pas parler d'android rien aucune 1
pourrait du tout on à magic loi et donc
si vous avez magic uraï normalement de
tourner sur un android 9 passes ça on en
reparlera déjà parlé dans ma précédente
vidéo il ya du problème entre huawei
honor et google mais ça mara prochaine
aujourd'hui on a un autre qui est
intéressant au niveau du son il ya le
virtual 9 points seulement bangalore ce
qui est intéressant avec ça c'est un
maul seulement lorsque vous allez goûter
aux écouteurs ou au casque vous
permettra vraiment confié dans sont
beaucoup plus immersif et il ya
également un mode hors cause écouter au
casque pour réduire la fatigue auditive
et en termes de tarifs sur le modèle
normal si j'ai gardé un plus en matière
de stockage on à 499 euros et sur le 8
gigas de ram 256 go de stockage
on est à 599 euros qu'est ce qu'il en
pense pourquoi saint guillaume du tout
ça mais comme à chaque nouvelle annonce
serré semaine toujours plus grand
toujours plus fort on attend de tester
surtout beaucoup beaucoup dénoncent et
quelques mois le pétrole et à une
semaine le one + seven co cette fois on
est sur le haut niveau
j'aime bien les procédés mangeant
professionnalisme beaucoup d'invendus
smartphone faisait remarquer en fait ils
se mettent tous sur la photo
là dessus on vient nous chercher en
disant tiens regarde et on les a
photographiés la lune bon alors c'est
vrai au delà du côté un peu what the
fuck de la lune est ce qu'on y arrive
oui toi comment est ce qu'elle est posée
sur un ps qu'il est hyper stabiliser
parler des conditions ici arrivé le
premier à la main comme ça c'est pas le
sens du x 30 pour montrer qu'ils savent
faire du foie 30 mai qui est dégueulasse
donc
c'est pas terrible ça sert pas à grand
côté un peu what the fuck messages sur
des photos avec le 40 8 mégapixels on
arrive alors des photos en pleine
lumière qui sont vraiment présent là où
ils ont un atout à jouer c'est sûr le
cmfi 30 2 mégapixels par exemple on va
voir ce qui donne par rapport à celle
vous avez trop petite caméra là vous
avez l'autofocus laser qui est là ça
c'est le maquereau c'est beau c'est bien
c'est sympa non moi je trouve pas mal je
trouve qu'ils ont fait un beau boulot au
niveau c'est un joli smartphones ils ont
leur bulle internet c'est vraiment
intéressant comme sa chasse la
révolution de pop de l'histoire du
smartphone mais ça c'est sympa
le fait d'avoir pareil comme ça se fait
beaucoup aujourd'hui le petit haut
parleur qui est caché là bon c'est un
truc est très sympa le design est sympa
et jolie et là vous avez modèle
spécialement dit qu'au design et avec
moschino vous regardez les et six notes
moschino bonne bon après avis aux
amateurs vous aimez vous n'est pas
exactement les mêmes faits que vous
retrouvez dans le nord 20 pro mais d'un
point de vue design c'est très sympa et
on vend on va draguer un petit peu là la
cible plus pense fashion le côté plus ce
n'est pas ce programmeur à laisse alors
ça sympa parce que vous en penser
comment vous trouvez vous pas que moi ça
directement en bas
vidéo non mais la technique belge du
tube heures tu vois un macbook avec un
power donc pour pouvoir recharger le
coup j'ai 10 % de batteries depuis une
heure de paris par rapport à charge et
ton macbook pro avec une probable ouais
mais celle-là est pas adapté cela c'est
un truc de smartphones nokia met sa main
sur la batterie mais c'est de la merde
vous aurez un truc adapté je n'ai pas
comme ça va on sait qu'on est en pleine
crise en ce moment avec web google au
nord donc c'est relativement difficile
on n'a absolument pas parlé à aucun
moment google très clairement à aucun
moment il parle d'android on parle juste
de magic your eyes pas plus aucune info
sur la date de sortie et en plus
normalement quand on est une conférence
de au nord on la presse on repart
toujours avec le smartphone pour aller
tester pour qu'ils puissent ensuite il
vend des articles des thèses des choses
comme ça
la pâte smartphones on a eu l'info
vraiment la dernière minute donc c'est
vrai qu'on sent vraiment que c'est un
grosse grosse grosse période de crise
personne ne parle absolument du problème
avec google on parle pas de l' os on
marque comme une souris n'y a absolument
aucune date
il ya plein de bruits de couloirs qui
tournent tous les côtés donc ça qu'on
est un peu dans l'incertitude c'est ce
qui très très très délicat très
difficile pour moi ou pour au nord
l'info est tombée la veille du lancement
officiel du smartphone donc été obligé
de maintenir l'événement
mais ces grosses situations crise très
compliqué ton absolument pas communiqué
dessus
le truc qui est sûr et qu'on sait
maintenant c'est que le nord va pas
sortir en france parce qu'il a déjà été
produit
ils ont déjà la licence google donc ça y
aura absolument aucun problème on
retrouvera j'ai pas encore la date par
trois d'ici quelque temps donc on en
reparlera quant aux eaux nord 20 pro on
n'a pas d'information si la licence ils
l'ont oui ou non je ne sais pas est ce
qu'il a été commencé à être produit oui
non pas comment pas d'information
là-dessus donc là on reste un peu comme
dans le doute à savoir si ces honneurs
20 pro sortira si oui quand comment bon
voilà ça pour l'instant je ne sais pas
et une fois de plus je vous le dis pour
tout savoir je l'invite dès maintenant à
vous abonner comme ça dès que j'aurai
des informations noël je vous dirai tout
comme ça vous serez au courant
il est sponsorisé par picard
alors attends c'est comme ça qu'on
bloque chez monsieur dreux bon alors
aujourd'hui on a vu le aux normes non la
paperie tout simplement parce qu'il
n'est pas disponible
et là je fais un gros zoom je fais non
il n'était pas disponible avec les
concepteurs c'est trop cool ça me saoule
ou sac c'est vrai que c'est beau je fais
toi roger ce soir gusto toi on va rester
une souris qui est passé entre nous tu
bluffes mec non mondiale est bien là et
me donc du pain pour les rajaouis
effectivement qu'il y est c'est chinon
sous le band c'est maître splinter
salut les gars
à bientôt je vais faire mon tatouage
et concours